[Music]
so
um a couple days ago i played the sunday
wave and joy of pessy sent this to me
and i needed to play this for you i i
just more than anything i needed you to
see this
if you ever need me to see something
just say the joy of pessy sent it he's
always
it's always good right he's always he's
such a weirdo i love him
so there was the show in the uk it was
like not a show but a little special
they did
um right after uh
in the year 2000 you know yeah 2000. we
need
flashlights uh so in 1999 they did this
and this is the a message for the new
millennium
okay hello i'm carolyn ashton
and i guess 24 hours on the world hasn't
ended after all
so happy new year in fact happy new
millennium
now over the past couple of weeks that
music really says
new millennials telling you about that
so without further ado so i'm going to
skip ahead so basically this is them
interviewing just people giving a
message to the new millennium okay
let's see what the people from the
middle east have to say
[Applause]
she hit the post hi i'm andy latham
town crier of rugby
oh yay
yays a town criers bow
has fertility powers come
ring my bell make millennium babies
god save the queen bring in
the year 2000 [ __ ] taste
very bad now watch this i want i'm not
going to say anything
i want to see if you pick up what i pick
up with this one okay hey
and this is bradley and my message for
the millennium is to my boyfriend nathan
first i'd like to apologize for those
terrible mood swings i've had since
having bradley
that nearly ruined our relationship but
thanks to you
all your love and support we've managed
to get through it and as you can see
we've got this beautiful little boy
so the one thing left me to say is my
request for the millennium
nathan i love you and will you marry me
she's the problem in the relationship
and to go on national tv
okay let's go on the bbc
it's [ __ ] insane right it's a [ __ ]
lunatic
why would you put your stuff out there i
don't know and by the way nowadays it's
like
you guys you you younger folks may not
even remember a world where
people didn't air their laundry like
this like you're all social media kids
so you probably think it's normal to be
like yeah i had a miscarriage just post
it on face
like normal people don't do that back
then this was
exceptionally insane for somebody to go
on tv and be like
sore forming mood swings mate will you
marry me
okay now i don't know if this is the
same guy but i think it is the next one
hello my name is craig and my message is
going out to my son joshua
who's four hi josh it's daddy here
i'm sorry i haven't seen you for a long
time son but as you know mommy and i
don't live together anymore
and she's got a new man in her life and
mommy doesn't want things to be too
complicated with having two daddies for
you so
what i wanted to say to you was i'll
always be here for you
i'll always love you and i'm always
thinking of you
and i'm sorry you're going to grow up
without your real father in a country
where you're slowly going to be a hated
minority sorry son
chip chip cheerio i could see you in the
new year
you'd make me the happiest man alive
hope to see you soon son
bye hi my name's jane
jane's my favorite i'm just going to
point out jane is my favorite is jane
being played by rebel wilson
jess she wishes you'll see why hi my
name's jane
and my message goes out to a very
special person called jim
jim i'd just like to say to you you
recently proved to me that you are worth
your weight in gold
you know what i mean there and if anyone
deserves a medal
you deserve an oscar you asked me to
marry you
eight years ago and i declined the offer
but
if the offer is still there nine years
on i'd love to accept
the answer is yes
so you know what i think happened here
well i think i know what happened too
but please
i believe that uh j just j
james whatever his name is is a really
nice guy and she was like
no i want to party i want to party and
go [ __ ]
[ __ ] barty and then after she
realized that noah
the the [ __ ] the line around the
block of dicks that she took
her [ __ ] wasn't enough to fill the hole
in her heart
she went back to the one guy who was
nice to her
didn't even go back to him just went on
tv and i hoped the message would get to
him because she's
even lazy now about it but yeah no no
what happened was is that
you realize that nobody wants to marry a
30 year old with 150 miles a thousand
miles on a vagina
and now you're like uh jim where are you
where are you jim
goofy boots is right eight years ago and
50 pounds lighter
[Music]
yeah she's like i know you're worth your
weight in gold not quite worth my weight
in gold
but worth your weight in gold thor my
heart
and here's to a great year 2000
[Music]
what is this monster and why are you
showing a girl scout outfit
she recently killed a girl scout
seriously for their pelts
are we killing girl scouts for their
belts now this next guy is my winner is
a winner to me this chick could get it
he's written in the ancient prophecies
that the time lord merlin
will reappear for the next millennium in
a huge you know what can i just
i'm sorry sure i'm glad i'm everything
that's happening to you british people
you
you deserve every ounce of it i want you
to know that
from the bottom of my heart everything
that's happening to you you deserve
i mean everything that's happening to
america by the way in our own unique way
we also deserve
but you're getting your own unique brand
of god's justice and we are too
this guy's a wizard bro this is the guy
owen's always talking about
he's not a wizard royce he's wearing a
costume from party city
with a huge dome over the top well i'm
here what's not called party city over
there it's called banquet town
but yeah
banquet village upon
here i'm back so all you people out
there
smile be happy and i will bring you
fantastic look for the next century
hi i'm beth and i'd love to be a singer
in the next millennium and i've written
a song about it
i don't think she became a singer and
that little girl grew up to be adele
well let's see her voice because she
sings now i'm looking forward to some
different kind of life
when will i get there where what is this
from this is from bbc really yeah so
yeah so it was a little special they did
for the new year
for 19 in 2000 right after the new year
so we needed
right we needed yeah between this and we
needed a shot in the arm oh yeah yeah
absolutely we got cocky to follow on
from me
i hope they'll live in liberty and peace
i don't know i don't know what it's all
about
i don't know i don't know what will come
about
i was watching the um last night i was
just re-watching the roast of rob lowe
was actually very good so jimmy carr
came up and jeweled was there jewel was
at the roast and he was like
wow jewel she has a lovely voice and a
beautiful body
and a face
and then the other one that killed me
was jimmy carr goes to him you know a
lot of people said rob lowe that you
know you were like a ken doll
uh mostly because uh much like a ken
doll you're the first thing a kid's had
in their vagina
that's a [ __ ] rough one right yeah
wow
loud everything is so confusing my words
are down and topsy-turvy but my message
to
you is welcome to the new world
it's not good though kid trust me go
back stay there if you can go back
stay there go back and then this this
hunk
it's been all downhill since the new
millennium right oh yeah of course
yeah look at this hunk hello
my name is jonathan from cardiff and i
know that a lot of you will be
gonna strip partying in the middle enjoy
yourself boom boom meeting new people
going to parties but just think of
those of us that have to work over the
millennium as kisser grahams
my message to you but wait do you have
to get naked for a kiss or grandma yeah
your kit off
[Applause]
well i i swear to god if i hear that
stinger one more time i'm gonna [ __ ]
scream so um then i'm very shocked
that song is [ __ ] that really is a
flashback though isn't it
remember that [ __ ] song
this is barefoot doctor spiritually you
observe the 21st century we deserve
everything
in the back of your brain this is by the
way i want you guys to know
this is what this is what life was it
was so
chill i know it was so chill and it was
like
we were kids but it's almost like we
should have known like we should have
just one day been like
are things too good like are things just
too
easy because everything was a breeze up
until
like i'd say 2002
even like right like 9 11. because none
of them kind of united us a bit so we
have a little
little uh unity thing afterwards it just
fell apart
seeing at the infamous and legendary
desmond club on koh samui in thailand
the desmond club has a difference and
this is especially for gram the baptist
daisy jane and carlos fandango
what's carlos fandango up to now man
well i mean we're like
probably dead of an acid attack in
family south
south asian very millennium i have seen
the future
and the future is bright and it's sir
you're in the wrong timeline then
it's the movie bright and cbs you're in
the wrong timeline and then of course uh
what about a quick little musical
interlude hello oh no
my name's adam and my millennium message
is to keep music
all right guys let's play a new game
it's called or british
well i just i just thought it was hammy
i'm just
for four people young young hammond
christopher
you're there you're there frozen you're
gonna get a laughing hey frozen is it
young hammy
i i miss brain too
[Laughter]
ladies and gentlemen frankie mcdonald on
the side
[Music]
at least he can play better than the
singing one
happy new year thank you now my favorite
one this next song is called
none of my countrymen look like me
anymore
so this one's one that i really wanted
to show this is my favorite one i left
the best how many of these are there
this is the last one this is the last
one but i mean i'm not even mad i'm just
saying how many were there
if you could find me more please send
them to me i will happily accept them
hi i'm you and i'm from scotland a nice
straight boy look at his shirt
i'm 16 years old and i've recently came
out my message for the millennium is
i think that they major consent for
young gay lesbian bisexual and
transsexual people
should be lowered to 16. what
why he's also 16. no i know but
you know what you know it's weird when
you're all right so
here's the thing right when you're 16
because i know the age of consent
technically you can't consent under 18.
but i'm gonna let you in on a little
secret there young man
by the way i was wondering where that
came from the other day very funny yes
um but i'm gonna let you know a little
secret
did you know that when you're 16 you can
[ __ ]
other people that are 16 and below 18. i
don't know if you knew that
so it's not that you can't [ __ ] the age
of consent laws have less to do with
you not it's like we know that teenagers
are [ __ ] right
but we would just prefer if they kept it
compartmentalized to [ __ ] other
teenagers
you know it's practice we try to just
keep the adults and the kids separate
they let that go in 2000 oh one low to
age of consent
even in 2000 that would have been spicy
right it would have i mean but i'm
wondering
let me know hi i'm yuan i'm from
scotland i'm [ __ ] weird i'm 16 years
old and i've recently came out
my message for the millennium is i think
that major consent for young gay
lesbian bisexual and transsexual people
should be lowered to 16.
millennium
um according to pessi that was one of
the ones that got cut
oh that was on the cutting room floor
yeah yeah
oh okay well i'm glad that this was made
quickly for you so there you go mike
you're probably so he was a pioneer
they also made this how come royce gets
the cool one well it's not cool
i would rather be the other one right
it's joe scarborough so
scarborough are you kidding me well it's
cool cause your face is on him now oh
you just have to take that morning joe
logo off put a day wave logo
someone's probably already working on it
oh
[ __ ] wait if you're gonna if somebody's
gonna photoshop him
can you put the art don't put out day
wave put rotc on his thing so that you
can make me his wife can you make me the
[ __ ]
that would be hilarious someone make me
what's her face
i thought you would i thought you would
enjoy that so for those people looking
for the video it's called the message
for the millennium
by the way who wrote that bad song what
was that who was that bad song by
somebody figured that it might be
it feels like a moby song somebody will
figure it out frozen find out who wrote
that song
now uh go you know the cool part about
this video is is how much gold is in it
and it only has 240 views
i mean there's a lot of vh vhs
wonderland 2 is actually a good channel
it's fantastic i'll post a link for you
guys if you guys want it
here you go